if you want to learn how you can win a
free ceases world hoodie to keep you
warm this holiday season then stick
around to the end of this video welcome
to a very merry episode of things you
missed because today we're covering the
2006 version of Black Christmas so
really it's not to marry at all if
you're looking for a happier holiday
video go watch my episode on the
original movie but if you're staying
here then let's get into the things you
missed at the beginning we see Claire
writing and reading - drinking red wine
wait don't go in the closet Claire red
means dead don't go in it why does
nobody ever listen to me in this movie
we're shown a little bit more of the
backstory about the killer Billy we
first meet him confined in a facility
known as the Clarke sanitarium this is
an homage to Bob Clark the man who
directed the 1974 version of Black
Christmas but that's not the only
tribute to him in this movie why
Christmas is not the most well-known
Christmas movie that Clark has directed
because he also directed the comedy a
Christmas story in 1983 the most iconic
prop from that movie really one of the
most iconic props from any movie is the
leg lamp that mr. Parker wins in a
contest much to the dismay of his wife
in black Christmas the lamp can be seen
in the background in the girls living
room but that's not the only at
Christmas story reference scene in the
movie when Ralphie finally gets his BB
gun for Christmas and shoots his eye out
his glasses end up saving him so he
makes up a story for his mom about how
an icicle came down and broke his
spectacles Rolex well there just happens
to be one victim in black Christmas who
isn't murdered by anyone but rather
falls prey to a deadly icicle and that's
mrs. Mack the house mother she's played
by Andrea Martin who graduated to that
role after playing one of the sorority
girls filmed back in the original black
Christmas the next one is in my own
discovery but I saw something online
about it so I thought I'd give it a
mention each one of the girls is named
after a singer who made a well-known
Christmas song Kelly Presley for Elvis
Presley
Karishma melissa kits for Eartha Kitt's
Santa Baby
Dana Mathis for johnny mathis Claire
Crosby for Bing Crosby Lee Colvin for
Shawn Colvin Meagan Helms for Bobby
Helms and finally Heather Fitzgerald for
Ella Fitzgerald I think that's enough
Christmas music for for like ever one
thing that this remake does that I liked
was have elements of the original but
the script is totally different some of
those elements include Agnes and Billy
using plastic wrap for a kill having the
killer set up shop in the Attic using
the disturbing phone calls made from
inside the house to frighten the girls
this time using each victims cell phone
because those exist now can you hear me
now good
the weapon used in Billy's most iconic
kill from the original movie shown to be
a gift given in the girls Secret Santa
exchange
on a sidenote Eve is the name of the
girl who delivers the murder weapon on
Christmas Eve
that sounds possibly intentional but not
really that interesting and most notably
making the killer is obsessed with eyes
and people's to give more meaning to the
most iconic shot from the original eyes
continue to show up throughout the movie
for seemingly no reason then like some
of the wall are at work and Megan screen
say speaking of Megan's computer I don't
think it's entirely clear what was going
on when Kyle shows up so let me run
through that subplot really quick Kyle's
shown to be dating Kelly when she gets
out of the car he gets on the phone with
Megan we don't hear the conversation but
we later see Kyle in a video with Megan
let's just say it would end up in the
adult section of the video store had it
been the pre-internet days Kyle probably
doesn't want his girlfriend to find out
so we can assume that's what the earlier
argument was about
he later climbs into Megan's room
probably to confront her about it maybe
steal back the video but he gets caught
and he tells his girlfriend that he was
trying to climb into her
room but the window is closed so he
wanted to Megan's instead and then in
the background and this is only on
screen for a moment it seems that Megan
has posted the video on a message board
called sea pupils which I guess
specializes in home made videos from
college students the users of the site
looked like perfectly normal
well-adjusted individuals also one other
note on Megan's room she has this poster
for a ray V Annette's concert with an
insane looking depiction of the male
female rock duo a clue that the
antagonists of this movie would also be
a mentally depleted guy girl team Billy
and Agnes when we see into Billy's
childhood the first present he gets is a
satellite and the other one is a
telescope both things that fit into the
theme of surveillance and voyeurism we
see how Billy gets his people kinked
from a very young age and watches his
parents fight through door cracks and
holes in the architecture when Heather
finds the collection of newspapers
hidden in the wall there's an article
about the night that Billy attacked his
family on Christmas where we see the
origin of the movies title the massacre
was dubbed by the media as black
Christmas after Kelly and Lee make it
out of the house to the hospital is what
I think is the most horrifying part of
the movie I mean I guess they felt like
they had to fit in the Christmas
carolers from the original film somehow
so they got a bunch of grown adults
dressed like some steampunk 1930s
looking thing and this I mean this this
thing should be the killer this is
terrifying anyway I don't have anything
else for this one if you haven't seen it
it's more gross than it is scaring so
I'm not really into that but I do have
something for you it's a little holiday
gift to keep you warm during your
Christmas horror movie marathons this
December I'm giving away a seize world
hoodie all you have to do to get your
hands on it it's following me on
Instagram and like this post full rules
are in the description remember
subscribe I seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week wring that death
battle for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]
you